bladesmiths congratulations you fellas
have made it into the final round of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home forges to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
general george washington's lion headed
cut toe
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days
so my bill is going to be made out of
1084
and 15 n20 really good contrasting
steals for damascus
the last time i did my saber build for
the army episode
i went with the damascus the damascus it
is a risk
because there's multiple things that
could go wrong from cold shots to
stress fractures but as long as my blade
does perform as i expect it to
my damascus is going to be that thing
that puts me over the top
here we are again back in springfield
virginia at my home forge
the plan for today is to cut out a
billet for the sword
so this wood anvil as they call under
the log whap method
they put a gentle arc in the blade
that's the same log that i use for the
mammaluke sword for the marine
competition it worked before if it's not
broken don't fix it
day two i gotta get this blade quench
today and
i'm gonna make some changes to the way i
do it in my forge i'm going to try using
the tube method main goal is to take
this tube
and just turn it into a nice long hot
oven
had a little bit of issues getting even
heat last time
so i think with that tube it should give
me a nice more even controlled heat
i don't hear any cracks pings or
anything like that
i nailed it it's exactly what i needed
to be
anyway day four finally here i'm feeling
ready i have a plan
and i have some hurdles to get over the
biggest one roars is that lion head
pommel
first thing this morning i'm gonna put
that thing in plaster paris and let it
set
i wonder if i should do it with pewter
you don't have to get pewter nearly as
hot
it'll be shiny and look just like silver
like garbage i think i'm gonna go with
the silver one just because of the look
of the silver right now i need to finish
the line head
polish everything and sharpen the blade
try to take some weight off anywhere
that i possibly can and then put it all
together
whoa it's done it's done
day four final day i've never
carved a problem before so i don't know
how long it's gonna take
and i'm gonna have to put some time into
it so i'm just
profiling from one way right now the
shape of the lion's head
to kind of refine it to what my final
shape is gonna be
and then i start removing some more
material a little fine-tuning with my
rotary tool
pretty much looks like a lion to me
all right veterans welcome to the keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
weapon to deliver killing blows
to this big carcass tyler you're up
first ready
okay i'm ready
[Music]
so
all right tyler your handle construction
just right
your edge is very sharp
overall sir this saber will kill
perfect all right gene your turn sir are
you ready
let's do this doug
[Music]
all right genes this is a heavy sword
very forward heavy
but when you have a forward heavy blade
that you're hitting that needs
resistance
a cylindrical almost circular handle
makes a twist in my hand so probably
this is the reason why the chain came
off
but your blade is sharp it will kill
all right gentlemen december 25th 1776
george washington leads the continental
army across a frozen delaware river to
attack the hessians
at trenton new jersey and he probably
didn't chip his way through the ice but
that's not gonna keep us from our
strength test
the ice block chop tyler you're up first
are you ready
uh yeah yeah let's do it
all right so tyler your chain fell off
but there's no damage on your edge
your handle's comfortable other than the
chain you nailed it
good job all right gene do it
all right gene your blade's edge is
still there
and it's still sharp the issue is the
rest of your chain fell off
and it's picked up a bend i have less
issue with that
and more issue with this polished handle
it's just hard to hold on to but it is
strong
and it does have an edge so good job
yeah
all right veterans our sharpness test
today is the hessian charge
this is all about what your edge will do
to these gummies
tyler up first you ready for this yep
all right tyler the weight of your
weapon does prevent me from going very
fast
but you have a very sharp edge all the
way through your weapon sir
it will cut thank you all right gene
it's your turn sir are you ready let's
do this doug
all right gene to be able to maintain a
good grip on this
more of the cuts i create are more
impact as opposed to a slash where it
cuts all the way through
so you have some cuts here that are more
nicks deep knicks because you have a
very sharp edge
and for this test sir your weapon will
cut
awesome tyler gene first of all i want
to thank you both for your service
you're both champions in my mind you've
already won
your branch divisions but there can only
be one battle of the branches champion
and you'll walk out of here with a check
for 50 000
and that champion is
tyler congratulations you are the battle
of the branches forged and fire champion
gene please surrender your blade
there's a lot of marines out there and
there's a lot of great guys in the
marine corps
and so for me to stand here and
represent them is pretty humbling
i learned too that it's not about uh
just the mello being forged in fire
i feel like i've been forged in fire and
it's how you handle the ups and downs
the wins the losses
and it'll determine real quick how
you've been heat treated throughout your
life
tyler congratulations you overcame every
obstacle set in front of you
you beat out all the other smiths and
now you're the battle of the branches
forged and fired champion
that's a title that comes with a check
for 50
000 and most importantly
bragging rights good job my brother
please present your blade to the judges
i'm
super excited when this whole thing
started i had no idea how it was all
gonna turn out
feels good to have represented the army
the fact that i just won
fifty thousand dollars is starting to
set in i'm sergeant tyler hackmart
and i'm the new battle of the branches
champion
you